meine frage herr botschafter
sagen sie zu dem zustand im moment und
was sagen sie zu der französischen
revolution dem entwurf und werden sie
diesen text unterstützen
gar nicht ist das kann ich für mich
selbst sagen es gibt einige länder die
unsere haltung verstehen unsere position
nachvollziehen zu können
wir haben den französischen entworfen
kurz gesehen ich denke er wird heute zum
französischen botschaft da vorgelegt und
dann werden wir uns eine meinung bilden
sie haben technische schwierigkeiten ja
tatsächlich
vielen dank für das briefing
passend zu der eben gestellten frage zur
ukraine
putin hat ja anfangs von einer
speziellen militäroperationen in aus der
oz im osten der ukraine gesprochen jetzt
verbreitet sich über das ganze land wie
können sie das was jetzt vor ort
passiert eigentlich beschreiben
und michelbach hat gesagt dass hunderte
von zivilisten getötet wurden und sie
sagen gleichzeitig dass die russischen
truppen aber zivilisten doch gar nicht
ins visier genommen haben
wie
können sie das erklären diese diskrepanz
zwischen börsendienst nun der russische
präsident hat nicht gesagt dass sich um
eine spezielle militär operation handelt
er sagte vielmehr es war eine besondere
militär operation in der ukraine
wir müssen genau verstehen was passiert
und dafür müssen wir weit zurück in der
geschichte
es hat nichts
im jahre 2013 14 angefangen
der konflikt hat eine lange geschichte
und liegt noch viel weiter zurück
im 2014 gab es eine
unfassbare und es wurden diejenigen
verfolgt von einem werden einen moment
ich muss diesen telefonanruf
entgegennehmen
die firma ja ich habe gerade eine
information bekommen
nach der die
us-behörden
und weiteren schritt vorgelegt haben
gegen gemüt der russische föderation und
sie verletzen damit ihre
gastgeber pflichten
denn die kündigung
aus der russischen mission und persona
non grata sind und das land verlassen
müssen
ja es geht um un diplomaten
die russische mission wurde gerade
besucht und wir haben eine note erhalten
in der man
darum gebeten wurde nun zusammen mit dem
generalsekretär haben wir ja diese
schlichtung besprochen die schlichtung
mit dem gastgeberland das ja ihren
verpflichtungen nicht nachkommen
ich glaube
das ist eine ganz neue informationen die
ich gerade bekommen habe und deswegen
musste ich dass es geht um 12 diplomaten
die zur unerwünschten person erklärt
worden sind können sie uns die namen
verraten nein es geht um 12 aber die
namen kenne ich noch nicht
novaview at least sie sind nicht
betroffen das kann ich ihnen versprechen
das ist eine traurige nachricht
und wieder ein
demonstration von einer missachtung
dieser regeln die ein gastgeberland zu
beachten hat
nach der un theater diese pflichten es
gibt nach der wiener konvention und auch
nach der un-charta gewisse pflichten für
ein gastgeberland
was war der grund für diese geschichte
nun ich habe den text der note noch
nicht gelesen sobald ich mehr
informationen habe komme ich wieder auf
sie zu zurück zur ukraine der konflikt
hat eine lange geschichte
aber 2014
war wirklich eine schwelle überschritten
wurde
denn da ist etwas etwa 80 etwas langsam
entwickelt und in den jahren nach der
unabhängigkeit und das führte
letztendlich zu einem verfassungsbruch
und es gab dann proteste es gab dann
das meiden regime
acht jahre lang haben wir vergebens
versucht
zu erreichen dass die ukrainischen
behörden das abkommen vom ins beachten
nach 2015 war es vor allem so dass die
ukrainischen behörden sich für wasserbau
etage entschieden haben und dass sie
dann einfach
die ihre verpflichtungen nach dem
minsker abkommen ignoriert haben
versucht das auf ihre art und weise
auszulegen und das kann natürlich nicht
funktionieren und im januar/februar
als der westen juli um damit begonnen
hat den ukrainischen staat
auszustatten mit
tödlichen waffen
gremium resources und auch zu dem
zeitpunkt ins tor das
120.000
an der kontakt linie stationiert wurden
und deren präsenz wurde noch verstärkt
so wollen ist gab provokationen
dann war es gab
beschuss und wir haben dann begriffen
dass uns das nirgendwo hinführt und
dann gab es die anerkennung durch
präsident putin von den beiden
volksrepublik dann gab es die bitte um
beistand und deswegen haben wir dann
diese militärische operation im donbass
und der ukraine gestartet
und wie ich es heute schon erfolg
versammlung sagte ist das kein krieg den
wir gestartet haben der ist von der
ukraine gelöst worden
sie wissen doch alle dass
wir mehrfach gesagt haben dass wir
keinerlei militär operation im donbass
plan es sei denn dass die
ukrainischen militärischen behörden
eine direkte bedrohung aussprechen für
diese republik und genau das ist
passiert und wir haben glaubwürdige
belege dass militärische operation
geplant waren und deswegen mussten wir
uns zu diesem schritt
unvermeidlich entscheiden
es hat eine reihe von berichten gegeben
nach dem treffen im bus zwischen
russland und der ukraine
wie sehen sie das was würde der ukraine
wieder den frieden bringen und was würde
zum abzug der russischen streitkräfte
führen was würde da helfen dann noch
anschluss an die frage von valerij
immer mehr länder auf der
generalversammlung treten ans podium und
unterstützt und die ukraine und haben
den eindruck dass russland der angreifer
ist wie bewerten sie das ist das licht
an die isolierung
was der ukraine in frieden bringt nun da
haben sie ja eindeutig uns geäußert es
geht um eine
demilitarisierung und eine
entnazifizierung der ukraine
dort besteht eine eindeutige
unmittelbare gefahr für uns auch vor dem
hintergrund der geopolitischen
stabilität und der präsident hat es ja
gesagt fertigt heute dann morgen dann
könnte die ukraine in 30 oder 50 jahren
einigen nato mitglied werden damit würde
die nato an die russische grenze
heranrücken und das wäre eine
existenzielle bedrohung für uns so das
werden wir nicht zulassen
[Musik]
was der klinik in frieden bringt
darauf habe ich geantwortet
auch zu den gesprächen die an der grenze
zwischen der ukraine und belarus geführt
worden sind
diese gespräche sind erst einmal
abgeschlossen worden die einzelheiten
sind mir nicht bekannt
ich weiß aber dass
dort beschlossen worden ist weiter
miteinander zu sprechen wann und wo weiß
ich noch nicht vielleicht am gleichen
ort hatte
es irgend eine gemeinsame grundlage
gegeben bei den gesprächen
das weiß ich nicht genau einzuhalten
kenne ich wie gesagt nicht aber ich weiß
dass
hier erst einmal die bedingungen
aufgeführt worden sind die wir von den
ukrainern verlangen das ist allgemein
bekannt
dem italian und entnazifizierung der
ukraine
neutralität nicht in der nato keine
verlegung von waffen dorthin
bisher hat mir noch eine frage gestellt
zu meldungen über
100 zivilisten die getötet worden seien
es gibt da viele berichte auch viele
falschmeldungen den fabriken geradezu
fabriziert werden wir haben keine
glaubwürdigen angaben zu zivilen opfern
natürlich ist jeder krieg etwas
schlimmes da kann immer alles passieren
aber wenn man diese berichte als
glaubwürdig ansieht dann ist das doch
ziemlich leichtfertig und doch sehr
schwierig es ist doch so dass wir uns
einer massiven propaganda kampagne
ausgesetzt finden er gibt es troll
vertreten wo diese falschmeldungen
erfunden werden und verbreitet werden da
hat es viele beispiele gegeben
das ist ein krieg ist das wirklich ein
krieg nein dass ich eine besondere
militär operation wie man das gemeinhin
nennt ich würde rechts land krieg
sprechen denn das wäre
wie soll ich sagen
das wären unmittelbare militärische
feindseligkeiten wir sagen dazu dass wir
militärische ziele in der ukraine uns
vorne hier greifen keine
zivilisten keine zivile infrastruktur
keine städte an
könnte etwas zu retten
fragen sie haben da eine sehr
angeregte diskussion gesehen wir haben
es nicht gehört aber die körpersprache
war eindeutig
der präsident der sagt er verteidige nur
die un charta wie können sie das
kommentieren was würden sie da sein und
dann gibt es auch den begriff der
entnazifizierung der ukraine der
präsident ist jüdischer herkunft der
präsident der ukraine
sie sprechen von
entnazifizierung in der ukraine und der
präsident selbst ist jude was sagen sie
ich oder wir haben den genau zu
verzichtet er wegen seiner position zu
der kirche kritisiert
ich habe mit ihm gesprochen
ich habe gesagt dass ich an ähnlichen
fällen ähnliche positionen bezogen hat
bei syrien schicken
oder es hat viele fälle gegeben so seine
position
zurückhaltend da war aber sie sollten da
keine körpersprache sehen das war das
diplomatische protokoll dass er
vielleicht beachtet werden kann
dann noch der umstand dass sie lenski
jüdische an hat das spielt jedoch keine
rolle die wirkliche macht die politische
macht in der ukraine gehört den
radikalen den neonazis dort
sie fordern den präsidenten auch raus
sie haben eine eigene agenda die sie
verfolgen und sie halten die dinge in
der ukraine am laufen
präsident salih hatte 74 prozent der
stimmen bei der wahl bekommen und da hat
er dabei versprochen
dass wir erst einmal seine prioritäten
liste abzuarbeiten aber dann hat er sich
davon ein wenig abgesetzt und spielt
jetzt praktisch diesen radikalen und die
hände liegen
neonazi-organisation
die behaupten sie vertreten das
patriotische erbe oder in patriotischen
teil der ukraine
er hat gezeigt dass er schwach ist dafür
keinen politischen willen besitzt unter
den obwaltenden umständen und dass er
eben kein widerstand gegen die radikalen
leisten kann
die die wichtigste politische kraft
darstellen die triebkraft in der
heutigen ukraine
danke botschafter
noch eine kleine nachfrage
dazu dass russland hier von einer
existenziellen bedrohung spricht wenn
die ukraine der nato beitreten sollte
russland ist heute schon ein nachbarland
von nato mitgliedsländern
deshalb wäre es denn dann
anders wenn
die ukraine auch in die nato eintrete
wäre das dann noch eine noch größere
existenzielle bedrohung in ihren augen
oder wie sehen sie das
europäische politische führer haben viel
darüber gesprochen
wie
[Musik]
die aggression die invasion durch
russland in der ukraine
die europäische sicherheitsarchitektur
verändert würde nicht nur im augenblick
sondern noch für weitere jahrzehnte
können sie da einmal kommentieren und
ihre reaktion beschreiben ja wir sind
nachbar von nato-staaten und das war die
folge eines betrugs durch unsere
westlichen partner die damals
als die berliner mauer fiel
zum zeitpunkt der deutschen
wiedervereinigung und sagten und gesagt
hatten sie würden nicht über die grenzen
der ehemaligen ddr hinaus gehen und
unsere damaligen a ihre führung
sie wollten uns das glauben machen
müssen oder glaubten das sogar unsere
westlichen partner lösen nun ganz recht
es herbe jemals
derartige verpflichtungen oder zusagen
gegeben
aber es gibt dokumente es gibt
unterlagen darüber es war wirklich so
und die naive sowjetische führung
glaubte daran und jetzt wissen wir die
früchte dieser damaligen naivität ernten
und wir haben in der tat nato-staaten an
unseren grenzen
wir wissen dass die infrastruktur der
nato
während wir hier sprechen an die
russische grenze
gerückt wird dort werden übungen direkt
an der grenze der russischen föderation
durchgeführt wir haben der natur
angeboten eine einigung anzustreben
unsere truppen auch bei übungen immer
in einer bestimmten entfernung durch
erhalten um nicht zu provozieren
dieser aufruf ist schon vor langer zeit
an die nato ergangen uns und darauf
haben wir die eine reaktion bekommen ich
habe das letzte gespräch navarro von
stoltenberg in erinnerung
[Musik]
damals
hatte lagrive erneut daran erinnert
diese frage anzupacken rottenberg
drückte sich darum genau wie die ganze
nato und anderes raten
das nato
nur an unserer grenze steht oder in
großer nähe zu unserer staatsgrenze ist
natürlich eine bedrohung für mich das
ist
geopolitischer art und deswegen haben
wir den usa sein auto angeboten
einen ernsthaften dialog über
sicherheitsgarantien zu führen
dieses angebot ist schon
im oktober oder november letzten jahres
ergangen wir hatten unsere vorschläge
unterbreitet
da ging es ist die nicht erweiterung der
nato die nicht stationierung bestimmter
waffen in der nähe unserer grenze
und ein rückzug der nato auf die
positionen von 1997
dass wir eine faire lösung gewesen und
würde uns dann wieder dahin zu gehen wo
wir eine sicherheitsarchitektur hätten
die einen nutzen für alle teilnehmer
darstellt wird aber wir hielten eine
antwort in der wesentlichen alle unsere
vorstellungen zurückgewiesen worden und
sagte und jedes land habe das recht
seine eigenen verbündeten frei zu wählen
damit ragt vor allem brasilien ukraine
gemeint
noch über es wird andere etwas was auf
den usc gipfeln gesprochen worden ist
die unteilbarkeit der sicherheit heißt
es klar
wonach die sicherheit eines landes
nicht auf sicherheit auf kosten der
sicherheit eines anderen landes erreicht
werden dürfen das war eine verpflichtung
nicht irgendein absatz wegen einer
aussage schon eine erklärung
britische inflation ändert europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur ich würde sagen
die nato hat diese veränderung heute
schon
vorgenommen seit 1997
entgegen allen versprechen und
verheißungen zusagen von damals